[Musica]
parliamo di innovazione e vorrei partire
ricordando a tutti che l'innovazione
oggi è senza ombra di dubbio la
principale arma di cui dispongono le
imprese per competere con successo sul
mercato e questo è forse ancora più vero
per quelle imprese come molte delle
aziende italiane che non possono contare
su altre armi come la dimensione e
quindi le efficienze di scala che ne
conseguono
all accesso a fattori produttivi come il
lavoro all energia a costi competitivi
quindi l'innovazione oggi lo sappiamo
tutti è una priorità
in cima all'agenda di ogni imprenditore
e di ogni manager
tutti ne parlano ma forse non tutti
sanno esattamente che cosa sia nello
specifico l'innovazione io credo che sia
molto utile vederla e definirla come un
processo non è nient'altro che una serie
di azioni una serie di decisioni
attraverso cui un'impresa
un'organizzazione o noi stessi un
individuo generano un'idea per un nuovo
prodotto un nuovo servizio un nuovo modo
di fare le cose e poi la trasformano in
realtà
la sviluppano la rendono concreta e la
portano sul mercato tradizionalmente
direi fino a una ventina di anni fa
le imprese hanno ritenuto che per
innovare con successo fosse fondamentale
controllare avere al proprio interno
disporre internamente di tutte le
risorse le competenze le tecnologie le
idee e le conoscenze necessarie per
portare avanti questo processo l'idea di
fondo era molto semplice per rinnovare
di più dobbiamo investire di più
internamente assumere i migliori talenti
tecnici designer ingegneri scienziati e
aumentare anno dopo anno gli
investimenti nei nostri laboratori di
ricerca di ricerca e sviluppo
l'idea di fondo da qualcuno è stata
nominata closed innovation l'innovazione
chiusa il concetto secondo cui è
fondamentale per un'impresa per
rinnovare con continuità e quindi per
competere sul mercato fosse necessario
espandere continuamente approfondire
continuamente
proprio know how ossia la propria base
di competenze distintive ci sono
parecchi studi che mostrano che questo
modo di fare innovazione nelle
organizzazioni produce una sindrome
quella che qualcuno ha chiamato la
sindrome del non inventato qui quante
volte di fronte a un'idea uno stimolo
che proviene da fuori i confini di un
organizzazione ci siamo sentiti dire beh
questa cosa la sapremo fare meglio noi
ecco la sindrome del non inventato qui è
proprio questo la tendenza spesso anche
inconsapevole a giudicare come di minor
valore di minor potenziale un'idea un
contributo una soluzione che ci viene da
fuori qualcuno appunto la chiamata la
sindrome del non inventato di una
barriera culturale spesso inconsapevole
che incontriamo nelle organizzazioni
questo modo di fare innovazione che
abbiamo chiamato innovazione chiusa è
stato il modello dominante fino a circa
una una ventina di anni fa ma possiamo
ancora oggi considerarlo un approccio
all'innovazione efficace delle cose sono
profondamente cambiate negli ultimi 20
anni innanzitutto il processo di
innovazione è diventato molto più
complesso e molto più costoso per
rispondere alle esigenze dei clienti che
cambiano sempre più velocemente per far
fronte a una competizione che sempre più
globale e sempre più imprevedibile
oggi le organizzazioni devono innovare
incorporando nei loro prodotti o servizi
molte più tecnologie spesso con una
natura digitale rispetto a quanto
accadeva qualche anno fa prendiamo
l'esempio del mondo dell'automotive
c'è chi ritiene che da qui a tre anni la
parte principale del valore che verrà
creato nella filiera delle automotive
sarà relativa alla componente software e
non più all'hardware delle autovetture e
questo impone una profondissima
trasformazione nel modo di fare
innovazione delle imprese che lavorano
in questo settore
volenti o nolenti e in qualche forma lo
stanno già facendo devono diventare
capaci di sviluppare o quantomeno
integrare software e sistemi informatici
di varia natura e questo è molto
difficile come capirete farlo facendo
leva
confidando solo sulle proprie competenze
risorse e tecnologie
c'è un secondo fenomeno molto rilevante
ossia il fatto che oggi il ciclo di vita
di un nuovo prodotto di un nuovo
servizio dopo che è stato portato sul
mercato si è accorciato sensibilmente
ricordo le parole dell'amministratore
delegato di hewlett packard che qualche
anno fa diceva oggi i nostri prodotti
restano sul mercato tra 6 e 12 mesi
cinque anni prima stavano sul mercato
tra tre a cinque anni e questo fenomeno
di accelerazione del ciclo di
innovazione è un qualcosa che è comune a
tantissimi settori industriali lo
vediamo anche noi quando andiamo a
comprare un elettrodomestico a
mediaworld per fare un esempio
quindi oggi non solo innovare più
complesso ma bisogna farlo anche molto
molto più velocemente e quindi cosa
stanno facendo oggi le imprese più
innovative che risposta stanno dando a
questa sfida stanno investendo di più
internamente nei loro laboratori e
processi di ricerca sviluppo e
innovazione
in realtà non è proprio così prendete
l'esempio di apple
l'anno scorso apple ha investito il 5,4
per cento del suo fatturato in ricerca e
sviluppo
un dato molto lontano da quello di altre
imprese come microsoft o google che
hanno investito il 13 14 15 per cento
del loro fatturato in ricerca
innovazione e questa è una costante
della storia di apple degli ultimi 5 6
anni e non possiamo certo dire che non
sia state non continui ad essere
un'impresa molto molto innovativa quello
che le imprese che oggi sanno innovare
veramente hanno dimostrato di fare e
hanno imparato a fare è quello di far
evolvere il loro modello il loro
approccio all'innovazione da una logica
chiusa a una logica aperta oggi il
modello che queste imprese adottano si
chiama open innovation e che differenza
c'è tra il modello chiuso e il modello
aperto di innovazione l'idea è molto
semplice e si basa sul riconoscere che
oggi non è più sufficiente disporre al
proprio interno continuare ad investire
sulle proprie tecnologie sul proprio
know how
e forse più veloce più efficace e meno
costoso meno rischioso saper
identificare cercare utilizzare le idee
le competenze le tecnologie e il know
how che già esistono fuori dai confini
della nostra organizzazione
l'idea è molto affascinante poi bisogna
però metterla in pratica
ed esistono oggi tantissimi strumenti
molto concreti con cui si può dar corpo
a questo principio
alcuni sono anche molto noti e
utilizzati da tempo
prendiamo ad esempio il caso di alessi
che tutti conosciamo l'impresa che
produce accessori per la casa
nel corso degli anni 90 ha visto
crescere il suo fatturato da 20 a 100
milioni di euro
rivoluzionando il suo modello di
innovazione alessia cominciato a
lavorare sistematicamente con un network
di oltre 200 designer e architetti che
stavano fuori da alessi che l'hanno
aiutata re interpretare il significato
dei prodotti che l'impresa sviluppare
portava sul mercato
intercettando interpretando dei
cambiamenti culturali che in quegli anni
si stavano verificando nella nostra
società potete facilmente immaginare
quanto fosse più ampio il contributo di
creatività e di conoscenza che questa
rete di architetti di designer riuscita
a mettere a disposizione nell'impresa se
confrontato con quello che avrebbero
potuto fare i designer direttamente
assunti da alessi stessa 1 secondo
strumento è quello che consiste nel dar
vita a delle collaborazioni con
università centri di ricerca o imprese
che lavorano in settori completamente
diversi dal nostro per dar vita a dei
progetti di sviluppo di ampio respiro e
di lunga durata
un esempio in questo senso è dompé
farmaceutici che poco tempo fa ha creato
nel suo laboratorio di ricerca e
sviluppo in cui investe il 15 per cento
del suo fatturato
ogni anno un dipartimento che si chiama
proprio open innovation e cosa fa al
compito di sviluppare misurare far
crescere e utilizzare una rete di
relazioni con oltre 200 università e
centri di ricerca in giro per il mondo
con cui dompe in nuova quotidianamente è
la stessa cosa che ad esempio fa anche
co sberla nota impresa italiana nel
settore dell'automazione che collabora
con decine di università e centri di
ricerca in europa ma non solo cosmer
però fa qualcosa oltre e partner di
intel che è uno dei più grandi consorzi
di ricerca pre competitiva nel campo
della meccatronica al mondo che mette
insieme fa lavorare insieme oltre 30
imprese e centri di ricerca e università
che si scambiano continuamente idee
soluzioni e tecnologie per accelerare e
migliorare la capacità di innovare di
ciascuno dei partner di questo consorzio
pensate che negli ultimi anni cosa era
messo a punto 16 brevetti innovativi nel
campo dell'automazione sfruttando le
competenze e gli stimoli che provenivano
da questo consorzio ci sono però oggi
molti altri strumenti anche più
innovativi che l'impresa ha incominciato
ad utilizzare solo più recentemente per
fare open innovation ad esempio è in
netta crescita il numero di imprese che
collaborano sistematicamente e spesso
anche investono nel capitale di start up
o piccole imprese molto innovative nel
far questo aiutate anche dal ruolo di
ponte di collegamento svolto dagli
incubatori o gli acceleratori di imprese
come ad esempio poli hub che
l'incubatore di start up del politecnico
di milano che ospita più di 130 start up
innovative
ci sono poi oggi anche piattaforme
online non so se avete mai sentito
parlare di innocenti o dina insigma che
aiutano le imprese che vogliono innovare
a entrare in contatto con comunità di
tecnici ingegneri docenti universitari
in alcuni casi si tratta di centinaia di
migliaia se non milioni di quelli che
vengono chiamati solver che aiutano le
imprese che desiderano innovare a
trovare soluzioni innovative ai problemi
tecnici più complessi che si trovano ad
affrontare un altro strumento che negli
ultimi anni è sempre più utilizzato sono
i contest di innovazione e gli acton
sono degli strumenti attraverso cui le
imprese possono coinvolgere fornitori
clienti partner studenti docenti nel
generare nuovi concept per prodotti
servizi che poi vanno apportati
sul mercato un esempio interessante in
questo senso e la global packaging
challenge lanciata nel 2019 da amadori
la nota impresa nel settore
agroalimentare che ha coinvolto una
serie di fornitori attuali e futuri
dell'impresa stessa nel mettere a punto
delle soluzioni sostenibili per i
sistemi di imballaggio di amatori stesso
ed è stato un progetto di grandissimo
successo
il messaggio che volevo trasmettervi e
che oggi ci sono tantissimi strumenti
tantissimi tool che si possono usare per
concretizzare l'idea dell'innovazione
aperta e non sono degli strumenti a
disposizione solo delle grandi imprese
delle multinazionali
anzi forse utilizzare e sfruttare questi
strumenti è ancora più importante
diventa ancora più prioritario per le
piccole imprese come molte di quelle che
ci sono in italia nel nostro territorio
chiaramente per far questo bisogna
prendere consapevolezza di un cambio di
paradigma importante noi abbiamo sempre
creduto che fosse fondamentale per
rinnovare con successo disporre di un
solido know how un set di competenze di
tecnologie distintive che l'impresa
presidiava su cui investiva e che faceva
crescere nel tempo
oggi le imprese che abbiamo visto e
tutte le altre che hanno intrapreso una
strada verso l'open innovation hanno
capito che il know how non è più
sufficiente e hanno cominciato a
sviluppare quello che io chiamo il know
where cioè l'interconnessione con il
mondo esterno e la capacità di trovare
velocemente efficacemente prima dei miei
competitor dove stanno le idee le
soluzioni e le tecnologie che servono
per accelerare e rendere più efficace il
mio processo di innovazione
chiaramente per far questo bisogna
superare quella barriera culturale di
cui abbiamo parlato
la sindrome del non inventato qui è
fondamentale che le imprese capiscano
da un lato il valore intrinseco delle
idee delle soluzioni che provengono da
fuori dei suoi laboratori di ricerca e
sviluppo e in secondo luogo è
fondamentale che conoscano quegli
strumenti sappiano in cosa consistano e
sappiano come si mettono concretamente
in pratica ecco io credo che oggi questa
è la sfida principale per ogni impresa
saper mettere a terra il concetto di
l'open innovation e far evolvere la
propria filosofia il proprio approccio
all'innovazione da un modello chiuso
direi autoreferenziale verso questo
modello espansivo e interconnesso che
abbiamo chiamato innovazione aperta
[Applauso]
[Musica]